your whole good weapon nothing welcome
the coltan sale blowing this clip the
mission to see if our smartphones can
help us slow the spread of coronavirus
once we can finally leave the house
again
yeah I've been stuck at home for too
long playing video games but the best
way to understand the complicated world
of contact tracing with a controller
many states app developers and tech
companies are working on contact tracing
apps or exposure notification apps using
either Bluetooth or location services on
your phone these apps aim to help us
record who we've been in contact with in
people in close proximity report that
they have kovat 19 we can then self
isolate to slow the spread one of the
main goals of these apps help the human
contact tracers these public health
officials ask infected patients where
they've been and who they've interacted
with then they track them down and tell
them about their exposure to the virus
and recommend quarantine II but can this
really work first let me explain the
technology then how different real-world
situations might play out then we'll
talk about how this all might be a long
shot
[Music]
here's your first task download the
contact tracing app this is all opt-in
you aren't forced to turn it on if you
don't want to - technologies can be used
to track what people you come in contact
with Bluetooth and location Bluetooth is
beginning the most attention since
Google and Apple have put their support
behind it
teaming up to make a privacy focus
solution that works between iPhones and
Android phones eventually iOS and
Android will be able to provide
Bluetooth exposure notifications without
you needing to download an app the
coffee shop nearby has reopened ready to
see how Bluetooth works in this
situation so here we are your phone
constantly broadcasts via bluetooth a
unique string of numbers think of it
like unique tokens your phone is also
listening for those tokens if two phones
are in close proximity for about five
minutes or more they receive each
other's tokens and securely store it on
the phone as you go through your day and
spend time near people you collect other
tokens and others collect yours sadly
someone you are near tested positive for
Kovan 19 once a Public Health Authority
has verified that this person's app
reflects this and uploads the tokens
shared with other people near them
then your app downloads tokens
periodically to check for a match if you
have one of those tokens the app will
notify you that you are near someone who
tested positive for kovat ready to see
how location works in this situation
some apps record a time-stamped list of
everywhere you've been
this wouldn't be able to help with
knowing who you were next to but where
you were the trail of your movements can
give context if someone you were near
tested positive for kovat later they
would share their location trail with
contact tracers to help track down other
people you may have come in contact with
if used alongside Bluetooth it could
also give context to those notifications
there are a lot more privacy worries
when it comes to location data it makes
sense it can tie you to a specific place
and time in fact Apple and Google say
that app makers who want to take
advantage of its Bluetooth platform
cannot use location services but would
you need both bluetooth and location in
real-world situations
if you breeze by someone in an aisle or
even stood near someone for a few
minutes
bluetooth wouldn't capture it location
data wouldn't capture your indoor
location but it would show you where at
the store which could be helpful to you
or a contact tracer for retracing your
steps plus if multiple people tested
positive in that area public health
authorities could mandate cleaning the
location if you were surrounded by
dozens of people on a train or plane
blew two tokens would do their thing
location likely wouldn't be accurate or
even picked up if you didn't have
service bluetooth would do the trick if
someone seated near you reports testing
positive although your location would
also be helpful it seems like a pretty
big long shot for all of that to work
first people need to be okay with the
privacy trade-offs Google and Apple's
Bluetooth platform seems to be the most
privacy respecting choice engineered to
not reveal any personal information and
for most of your info to stay on the
phone each state will decide which app
it releases and what technology is used
for instance Utah's healthy together app
not only uses location services to
collect where you were but also requires
your name and phone number the maker of
the app says this is so health officials
can get in touch with those who test
positive it says all data is deleted
after 30 days the Apple and Google
Bluetooth technology should start to
show up in apps in late May the even
bigger hurdle that the vast majority of
people need to participate for that
Bluetooth app to work if nobody on the
train or coffee shop has the app it
won't do any good and then there's the
chance of false positives and for
detected just not work plus we need
widespread testing and people to be
honest and reported they're sick so yes
your smartphone may be a weapon in this
fight and it may help those human
contact tracers but a lot has to happen
for you to win the game and truly slow
the spread
[Music]